I don't know what good things we did to
deserve it but we've been given our
first look at the new bat suit for next
years with Batman so let's put that
footage in slow-mo and break down what
the suit tells us about the film right
now on the ketchup details surrounding
the Batman which is currently slated for
release on June 25th 2021 have been
slowly trickling out mostly thanks to
director Matt Reeves on social media and
fans are freaking out after he posted a
camera test on Vimeo recently that
features our first look at Robert
Pattinson in the new bat suit the man
knows how to get followers and aside
from those on Twitter who think the suit
and lighting resemble Netflix's
daredevil series one of the first things
that fans notice is the bat logo on the
chest which many feel looks like pieces
of a gun and not just any gun the gun
you know from Bruce's childhood this
serie actually stems from a Batman story
by Kevin Smith and artist Jim Lee and
last year's Detective Comics 1000 in it
Bruce Wayne forges the gun that killed
his parents into the armor of his bat
suit to quote protect his heart while
crime-fighting in which case let me know
when I can get one of those on Amazon
and speaking of armor this new bat suit
appears to be one of the more heavily
armored ones we've seen in the movies
that is if you don't count than athletes
wardrobe change into what kind of looks
like a cross between Lego Batman and
Robocop in Batman V Superman
but the armor on this new suit looks to
be made of several separate pieces which
should allow for a lot more movement
plus it looks like he has a collar
protecting his neck so you can actually
move his head from side to side
no offense Michael Keaton
and all this room for movement makes
total sense because it's been reported
that Pattinson has been training in
Brazilian jiu-jitsu with instructors
from the John wick movie so expect Rob's
version of the Caped Crusader to be
dabbling in some serious Hanahan combat
and because of the way the armor appears
on the shoulders and chest people have
also been drawing comparisons to bat
suits from a couple the video games like
2013's Arkham origins and 2015's Arkham
Knight and before I move on let me just
say every bad suit is beautiful in its
own way if you're lying I'll break the
other one now it's also worth noting a
few things from the neck up we all know
Rob's jawline is so sharp it could cut
through a wall but I'm referring more to
the visible stitching and leather vibe
that's going on with the cowl it's
giving off kind of a patchwork or
homemade feel and that actually fits
well with the reportedly younger version
of the character that we're gonna be
getting and even though we can't see the
ears just yet it is fun to speculate
whether they'll be short or long like
early comics long so let me know what
you think and maybe out there are some
money on it in Vegas all right before I
could get over to you guys I must remind
you that we have a full breakdown of the
super stack cast and potential
storylines for the Batman although I'd
like to add in my prediction of a Batman
and Catwoman love story right now while
we're on the record because they could
have matching stitched suits
so check out that episode if you haven't
already okay now we have to know where
does this bat suit rank for you in the
history of bat suits is it above or
below the George Clooney one with the
nipples one of my personal faves let us
know in the comments and don't forget to
join our ketchup fan group on Facebook
where you can vote in our polls and keep
conversations like this going all the
time and if you don't want to miss out
on any future episodes of the show hit
that subscribe button and a vacation
Bell as Zoey's we thank you so much for
watching the catching up I'm nice Perez
and we'll see you guys next time
[Music]
you